so what do you think drives you to pick
up these girls more than anything
what's your motivation to do it i like
hoes
yeah because i don't have to
deal with all the other [ __ ] um
i'm dating i pay them or i give them
dope
and they do what i want to do and i'm
finished but
now what if you find dating a woman that
isn't
working the streets a little more more
headaches and more problems
no i just yeah finding more headaches
more problems
and this is just easier but everything
that's easy
doesn't come free
you know this has driven me down the
road where
soon as i start doing cocaine
first thing i want to do is go get a
[ __ ] it's led my life into a
turmoil
and i keep thinking that i'm gonna find
a good woman
but i have to understand you can't
change anybody and i can't change them
and they do have good hearts but
the whole street life is just a bunch of
[ __ ] and scouts i understand
they got to do what they have to do but
it's dangerous
and uh my addictions brought me there
your addiction is what okay cocaine and
sex
yeah so that combination leads you here
yeah that mean
how many years you've been doing this
well um
the first time i picked up a prostitute
i was 19. and uh
i had a girlfriend i was just fascinated
that
you could pay a woman money actually do
what you want
so i ended up
i think it was down fig this was like
back in say 84.
and i was rolling down singing i found
one
but i soon come to find out that it's
about
money it's not a love thing it's not a
friend thing
i pay them they do what i want to do and
they're out
they ain't no talking involved they
don't give a [ __ ] about what i say
and i had learned that i shouldn't give
a [ __ ] about what they say and over a
period of time
i learned that i don't give a [ __ ] about
well i can't say that because they are
people and they're good people and i try
to
think about this when you're doing a
business transaction sexual transaction
it's it and you can try to be with them
and be a boyfriend with them or a friend
and you'll come to find out that it all
just turns [ __ ] because they're gonna
go [ __ ] somebody else
for money okay in a minute in a minute
who's ever got the most dope who's got
the most money
that's where they're headed you can
spend
all day with a [ __ ] and soon as you run
out of money and dope
she's going to next
and that's what they call being a trick
yeah and has it gotten in the way now of
your relationships with women outside of
that world
well i'm educated
so i know people on both sides i went to
devry
i have a four-year degree in computers
for major systems what do you do for
a living right now i do i t work
i got laid off i was working for
um maybe i should have said that i'll
take it out
okay and i was working for them
and but then i had a girlfriend that had
my child
we started having problems and she
used sex against me so then i said [ __ ]
it
i start going out and buying
yeah and what's the what's the craziest
experience you've had doing this
well the crazy experience i ever had was
where i was set up
this just happened about maybe a couple
of months ago
i was with this one girl and she said
okay well
i know where to get some dope at i said
well
i'm not going to spend any money i'm
just going to smoke with you she said no
fine i said
i said what do you do i do everything as
long as you smoke
took me over to a spot next thing i know
my car got surrounded that broke out the
windows
and uh i punched it
i ended up tearing up the car running
into a fence
chain leaf fence caught me like a net
like a fish
and i'm getting uh yeah nine staples
yeah and i was trying to and then
being the way i am i turned around and
tried to go back and hit him
again yeah
because that's the world that you live
in
you know it's doggy dog
and yeah you got some ones that that
that
that care about some people they're
people human beings but then they'll
turn on you in a minute
yeah you've been arrested doing this
never
cops are left never never um
what are they called pandering what they
call um solicitation
no never got arrested solicitation
because now
the police department or the law
they know what they do and it's like
it's
accepted they know they're selling dope
they know the whole situation
i guess they don't want to spend the
time yeah well i mean they're driving
down
fake and they see yeah they see it they
know exactly what they're doing
sometimes throughout some girls but what
twists me out now
is that the age of the girls
and i'm just like wow man look at these
women they're young
and um some of them um
don't know him someone's been killed i
know i know prostitutes
that were friends of mines but you know
that on that level
that gotten killed because they
uh jack somebody for their wallet a guy
came back and killed him
um
you've been married never been married
five kids
yeah got one uh 21 year old very proud
of him
he's in college he's about 6 4
3 30 offensive tackle
i pretty much raised him by myself
um his mother
left us when he was one wasn't behind no
drugs and she just
was a person that liked to go out she
moved to land to work for cupcake
so i had to i'll take that off too yeah
okay i had to change the way i
i looked at it you know as far as
raising the kid
but still my addiction was there
and my sexual addiction was there but i
was able to
keep it under control now that he got 19
i feel like i've done my job you're free
i'm free but i'm not free
the more you do it the more entangled
into the spiral
you get
i don't know sometimes i
i feel like um
i'm i'm really just shooting dice
and one day it's going to come up
perhaps
what are you worried about most well
i'm worried about
me getting into it with one of them
and having to defend myself like
the thing i'm gonna and then having to
deal with somebody else
because they always know somebody yeah
because you know it's a you know
they always know somebody or they always
try to threaten you with that
and i'm you know and
it's been a hell of a ride do you
believe in love
yeah i got hurt i was in love
twice and uh
both times i got hurt and i never wanted
and see that and that's the hell of a
question they asked me
because that's one of the main reasons
why they want to jump back into a
relationship
because i don't have to love in this
relationship there's just
you know what i mean you don't have to i
don't have to love them i don't have to
take care of them
and i'm sure it changes the way you see
women
yeah in terms of how much you trust them
well i see women now
on a different level because
even when i talk to a reg i see that
they all can be
a certain way it's about what they want
i can understand you know you giving
your wife or you know
doing things for your wife and your
girlfriend but
in a way we're all tricks
you know i'm just taking the easy way
out
but is your attitude that uh
regardless of what kind of relationship
it is you're also you're still paying
for it
i'm so paying for it i hear that a lot
so pamphlet
but you know man i'll tell you this
i'm tired of it and i really am because
there's so much drama
and so much trickeration and so much
[ __ ]
that it just puts you in a situation
where
aren't you tired of being sick tired
i'm tired
yeah so i'm you know now i know i got
two out there
and you know it's a certain type of
pride too you know
um because not only i don't have to pay
them money sometimes you know
i have them out there taking them on
runs
where i'll take them to the fig pick
them up
take them back and forth to buy dope so
i don't have to buy any dough you're
just hanging out with them hanging out
with them
but then you know when you treat it like
they'll say oh
i'll give you all i'll [ __ ] you or give
you all the [ __ ] you want
but then me i'm not that kind of person
where i'm very scared of catching
something
so uh i kind of like
touch them but i'm not going up in them
because uh i'm too old to be catching
aids or
stds and i've been lucky
very lucky do you miss the closeness or
intimacy
with the girl with a woman who really
gets you
definitely your personality is
definitely a woman that knows you
you have a connection that has a
connection with you because these are
just
yeah a woman that really cares about you
yeah
because talk is talk yeah you know none
of these people and i miss that because
someone that you can talk to that really
understands
and wants to and with you like you know
my mother and father were married for 62
years
and you don't find that
these days and i asked my mom
how did you and dad stay together so
long she said because
we didn't sweat the small stuff
you know young yet but we let it go i
mean and
it made their marriage stronger i'm 55
years old
and i may not ever be able to find
the right moment hopefully one day i
will but it
i have to change i have to change
it's great that you see that it's great
that you see that yeah i have to change
um but i'll tell you what
as soon as you take that for me i don't
know about everybody else
as soon as i take that first hit
i'm looking for a woman and it's not
just about sex it's just like
having a woman looking at her body you
know i'm just
you know just being around her even
though she's treacherous just to have
her
talk nice and smooth to me so which came
first the the crack addiction or the sex
addiction
the crack addiction but the sex edition
was always there
but it was undercover okay it was always
there
i was always looking even when i was
my cousin had told me say i used to as a
little boy to go up and rub
women's legs so i noticed that there was
a difference and i was like only three
or four
and i i think i lost my virginity at 13.
and then i mean i can just any woman
i see any woman i don't care if she's
not a [ __ ] or any i'm bam
i'm looking at her body i'm looking at
her because i you know i love everything
about a woman
everything about it her body shape it's
something i don't care what anybody says
there's something beautiful about every
woman
she might be the ugliest woman around
but it's something beautiful about
something i guess that's a gift from god
yeah yeah awesome
well reggie thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah very interesting
thank you
for being so hopefully honest thank you
thanks man
what's my family gonna say
you